I felt like because we were three
straight actors that we had to really
bring a lot of Integrity to these roles
into the storytelling we needed to
represent correctly and we were all all
of us were in you know and we went to
all the escuelita was this huge 42nd
street drag ball Latin and black and
then we went to Sally's and Sally's one
and two all the the famous drag bars of
the of the era we had drag queens that
were assigned to us to help us so I had
Larissa Dumont just Puerto Rican drag
queen from the South Bronx and would
work with me and teach me how to walk
teach me how to use my hands and then I
I I went vegetarian vegan for six months
before we shot so I would lose all my
muscle so I become like veal tender and
smooth